Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P Here is yet another
caller thinking it's time for me to
get corrected about the vaccine. Listen to this.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. Listening to your show now,
boy, you are doing some major backpedaling on what
you are guilty of with regards to the vaccine.
Speaker 1: I'm backpedaling now, but that
sounds interesting. Let's see if the voice
mail explains in what way I'm backpedaling.
Speaker 3: And how intolerant you were the
entire time of any. Real debate, any
open dialog, any scientific inquiry
for anything other than the vaccine. Even now you
just tell me all vitamin D is good for everything.
Guys like that. David, go back. In your own case.
Speaker 1: I've been saying all along the
same thing about vitamin D.
Speaker 3: And you can hear
used. You say, Anybody who says you need
vitamin D is an ANTI-VAXXER literally.
Speaker 1: Never said it.
Speaker 3: Should be shut down,
should be canceled. That was you. I
may have my suggestion to you, too.
Speaker 1: Well, my suggestion to you is to
criticize me for things I've actually said, sir.
Speaker 3: Kind of repair your credibility is play
some clips of some stuff that you played in 20,
20, 20, 21. You know, let's hear
it. Let's hear you. Get on. See
what I said here? I'm being a reasonable.
Speaker 1: So, listen, there has been no
backpedaling. Let's take these things one at
a time. Let's first talk about the vaccine.
The first vaccine tailored to the original COVID
variant, very effective at preventing infection
and transmission. It was a really good vaccine,
not only at keeping you out of the hospital and
alive if you got COVID, but it was a good vaccine
at preventing you from getting COVID at all. As
the virus changed and the vaccine started to be
modified to keep up with it, the vaccines became
less and less and less effective at preventing
infection. I at no point said anything other than
that, to the point where now the vaccine really is
about keeping you alive and keeping you out of the
hospital. It is not a vaccine that is preventing
infection at this point in time. I hope we can get
to one that does. At no point have I backpedaled
and at no point have I made a claim about that
that didn't match what was actually happening in
the real world. As far as vitamin D, vitamin D,
zinc, vitamin C, ivermectin, hydroxychloroquine,
we looked at all of these things and my approach
early was we don't have evidence right now that
these things prevent COVID or our treatments
for COVID. As we gained evidence, we learned,
okay, ivermectin doesn't work. We've now we
have a good test, we have a good trial, and it
doesn't work. Hydroxychloroquine doesn't work.
Vitamin C and zinc don't seem to do anything
to shorten the duration. Vitamin D does seem
like it is generally good for fighting off
infections all along. From the very beginning,
I said to everybody in my audience, I
supplement my vitamin D in the winter months.
Even if it doesn't do anything to prevent
or help you get over COVID specifically,
it is a good thing to maintain an adequate
level of vitamin D, and that continues to
be what I say. There has been no backpedaling
whatsoever, so please criticize me for things
I've said. Sometimes people criticize me for
things other hosts have said, and they're like,
Oh, I actually heard that on a different show.
But I guess it was David. I don't know if it's
an honest mistake. Apology accepted. I know
you're not going to apologize, sir, but
there has been no backpedaling. Thank you very
much. We're going to talk on the bonus show today
about the latest on student loan debt relief. We
are going to talk about Iowa legislators proposing
a ban on same sex marriage. I know it's 2023.
This is not a show from from 2013. It's 2023.
That's what they're proposing. Let's ban same
sex marriage. And we will talk about the post
office buying almost 10,000 electric vehicles
and 14,000 charging stations. Very interesting
stuff. All of it on today's bonus show. Sign up
and join Pact Mint.com and get instant access.